قبل فتره كان الرجلان قادرين على اخفاء
خلافاتهما والجلوس مع بعضهما لتخفيف
التوتر اما الان لم يعدوا الامر كذلك لجا
رئيسه مجلس السياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان دقلو الى ايصال
الرسائل لبعضهما في العلن حده وصل اليها
الاثنان بعد تباعد المواقف السياسيه
بينهما بشان تشكيل الحكومه ثم ما تسرب من
اتهام البرهان لنائبه باستغلال منصبه
السيادي لاجراء تحركات داخليه وخارجيه
سريه
مهم جدا نحن كعسكرين بيهمنا اللي قدامك
قوات الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه ده
نحن
الفيصل
اساسا متينا للمبادئ الرئيسيه فهذا
الاتفاق حزمه واحده يجب ان تنفذ كلها دون
تجزئه
غير ان اللافت بان الحرب الكلاميه الاخيره
لم تعد بين البرهان وحميتي انما دخل فيها
عضوان مجلس السياده شمس الدين كباشي وياسر
العطاء ليس هنالك دوله ديمو
حديثه محترمه بها جيشان وهما اللذان صمت
لفتره طويله ما فسر انهما ليس على وفاق مع
قائدهما واللافت ايضا ان الرسائل كانت تصل
الى دلل من الولايات وفي مناسبات اجتماعيه
ليست سياسيه
وخلاف نتيجه للتقاطع الفهم
لدباغ الايطالي
وخلاف بالنسبه للمستقبل السياسي للرجلين
لذلك جاء هذا الخلاف
وقوه سياسيه
تحاول ان تغازل
المركزين ما يتضح في هذا الخلاف هو تقارب
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي مع حميتي
ودفاع ناشطين عنه في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في وقت يبدو الطرف الاخر من
القوى السياسيه اقرب للبرهان وتنشط ايضا
حمله الدفاع عنه لا يمكن ان نصدر ادانا
لخطاب للخطاب الذي قدمه قائد الدعم السريع
والتزم فيه بكل ما جاء في الاتفاق الاطاري
لا يمكن ان نحول هذه الخطاب
لادانه رغم ان بضعه امتار فقط تفصل مكتب
رئيس مجلس السياده النائبه داخل القصر
الجمهوري الا ان الحوار بينهما بات برسائل
مشفره في العلن فهل يمضي الفطور بينهما ام
يجلسان لتخفيف التوتر لنعقوبه العربيه
الخرطوم